welcome to tony michael's
t-mike side piece so today we're going
to talk about
marjorie taylor green this [ __ ]
wackadoo
marjorie taylor green won her
congressional seat in
georgia and she's a dewey elected
official of congress unfortunately
she has a lot of crazy views she
believes that there are jewish
space lasers that set forest fires
she believes that the uh school shooting
at marjory stoneman douglas
was a false flag
so she believes that nancy pelosi
and the gun control lobby made sure that
this person would get a gun down there
go in and shoot and kill students so
that way that way
the country would be scared
and take away her guns this is [ __ ]
crazy she also believes that the vegas
shooting
at the country music concert country
music concert
was also a false flag she believes that
that person
was not a lone gunman that somehow he
acted with
other people i guess to scare
country music lovers into thinking that
we need gun control in this country
person certainly has a lot of mental
issues that she needs to deal with
obviously i don't know if she's
medicated or not but
maybe maybe someone should check into
some
uh health care for congress people at
this point
now a lot of people are calling for her
to be expelled
which i'm not against her being expelled
the problem is you have to have a reason
to expel her
i believe right now there is a petition
or a motion going around congress
there's
uh 50 co-sponsors that have signed on to
the
her expulsion that's still really not
enough members of congress to expel her
you need a two-thirds vote in the house
to actually expel her
i i don't think you would get that at
this point i mean there's a lot of
congressmen
that not only believe this crazy [ __ ]
that she believes
um and it's not a lot but there's a lot
of them that are pretending to believe
this stupid [ __ ] that she believes
a lot of them pretending to believe this
stupid [ __ ]
now i think the difference between her
and uh
knuckleheads like josh hawley or ted
cruz or kevin mccarthy or jim jordan or
matt yetz is this lady
believes this stuff she actually
[ __ ] believes it matt gatz jim jordan
ted cruz josh holly i believe that these
guys
these people they don't actually believe
this [ __ ]
they just pretend to believe this [ __ ]
so that way their constituents are
convinced that they believe
but this marjorie taylor green this
whack-a-doo
definitely definitely for sure believes
this
[ __ ] garbage about these conspiracy
theories she is a full-on
[ __ ] q and honor and not only is she
a q and on her she apparently
talked to the ex disgraced twice and
peach
fat slob president donald [ __ ] trump
on the phone from his bunker at
mar-a-lago
and apparently they're on the same
[ __ ] page here
well color me [ __ ] surprised that
these two morons are on the same [ __ ]
page are you [ __ ] kidding me
of course these two idiots think the
same
the mental instability here is [ __ ]
unbelievable
but we can't just expel her she's a duly
elected member of congress regardless of
how she was elected or what issue she
was elected on
the people in that district elected this
crazy [ __ ] loon
and she's gonna be a member of congress
for that district for two years
and possibly longer if they don't vote
her out
now the republicans could actually steve
king her and what i mean is they can
take all the committee responsibili
abilities uh
responsibilities away from her they can
basically handicap her in the house
to where she has she can't touch
anything she can't really do anything
and if you're if you're a member of
congress and you can't do
anything in the house you can't touch
anything or make things happen
uh normally your constituents say say
[ __ ] you
you're out we'll get someone who can be
on committees that's not a [ __ ] loony
and then we'll have some we'll have some
representation in congress just like
steve king of iowa
so this outright racist he decides he's
gonna keep being racist and it got to be
trouble for the republican leadership
so they decided to censor him by not
giving any
any committee assignments and basically
making to where he was a worthless
member of congress
and then you had a trumper in iowa
another trumper
and not so overtly racist uh
runs against him in the primary beats
him in the primary
which makes steve king not a congressman
anymore and that's certainly what they
could do here with marjory taylor greene
the problem is the [ __ ] problem
is she raises tons of money from these
crazy q and on people
and the republicans are like money
money money money money money money
money so they want the money they want
the money that this crazy lunatic is
[ __ ] raising from all these other
crazy lunatics
on the internet and that's where this is
coming down to they're not gonna pull
away her
her committee uh assignments as long as
she's handing over
175 000 i mean they're on phone calls
thanking her oh
thank you thank you for fundraising 175
000 we're so excited that you're in our
party by god maybe you'll be a leader
someday and really i mean i think that
gets at the heart of this thing
is let them let them deal with her
i mean if they're if she's going to be a
duly elected member of congress in this
in this district in georgia
let them pay the consequences let's just
keep trotching out
all the [ __ ] that this lady not only
that she believes
the [ __ ] that she says the [ __ ] that she
posts
as long as this lady's willing to be
crazy
let's let the republicans deal with that
amount of [ __ ]
crazy folks let's do it
[ __ ] um